خروج قطار نورفولك الجنوبي عن مساره
وتسرب مواد كيميائية سامة
تركها حي كريستينا فيرجسون تبحث
عن إجابات أريد أن أسمع أن كريك الخاص بي
سيكون واضحًا أريد أن تقول
مدينتي
إنها غير راضية عن
الاختبارات البيئية لأنها تقول أنه يمكنك شم
المواد الكيميائية بمجرد  يشعر
الكثيرون في مجتمعها بالقلق بنفس القدر
حتى عندما تقول الحاكمة إن
اختبارات جودة الهواء لأكثر من 500 منزل
أظهرت عدم اكتشاف أي ملوثات تخرج عن المسار، وأن
المياه آمنة للشرب
الأسبوع المقبل، وسيتعاون مسؤولو الصحة والبيئة الفيدراليون وأوهايو
لفحصها  سكان المجتمع والإجابة على
أي أسئلة، ستضم العيادة الصحية
خبراء في تأثيرات
التعرض الكيميائي المحتمل وفي الوقت نفسه
أنا واضح جدًا عندما أقول ما دام الأمر
يتطلب استمرار العمل في التنظيف، فقد
ذكرت وثيقة وكالة حماية البيئة التي نُشرت يوم الأربعاء أنه لا يزال هناك
احتمال  التربة الملوثة في
الموقع، هناك تحقيق مستمر من NTSB
أيضًا، حصلت CNN على
مقاطع فيديو للمراقبة تظهر
ارتفاع درجة حرارة محمل العجلة بشكل واضح، ولا توجد
شرارة مرئية قبل الساعة 8 مساءً بقليل،
ليلة الخروج عن المسار، ظهرت بوضوح
سباركس بعد 14 دقيقة، خرج القطار عن مساره
حوالي الساعة 8:55.
ما سبب ارتفاع درجة الحرارة وما إذا
كان مرتبطًا بالخروج عن المسار؟
يقول المسؤولون إن المياه العامة آمنة بينما يجب على
مستخدمي مياه الآبار الالتزام بالمياه المعبأة
في الوقت الحالي، هناك الكثير من البيانات ولكن
لأسباب كثيرة للقلق المستمر،
أنا أبلغ إميلي شميدت